this is the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky speaking in kiev
[Music]
against ukraine uh
it's a challenge not only for ukraine
but for the europe and the world as a
whole uh in ukraine uh the
afford the mistakes which were committed
back in georgia in 2008
we um
demand a new package of sanctions
against the aggression of ukraine it
should be uh including the full stop for
the uh north stream um uh gas pipe
uh grateful to estonia uh for the um uh
javelin um uh
rockets and uh the uh modern
military hospital this is a big help to
maintain the defensive capacities of
ukraine we also uh we're discussing the
crimean uh platform
of format um estonia um
totally
supports uh the the occupation of
ukrainian peninsula of crimea
and we also discussed the european and
uh uh euro integration
um uh aspirations of ukraine who are
which are fully supported by uh estonia
to on our way to the eu and uh a few
future way to nato and ukraine needs
those decisions we also discussed uh
different uh steps uh on activation of
mutual
cooperation in investments and trade
directions
and uh i'm sure the president
will discuss this uh talking to uh the
ukrainian uh prime minister
we are
also
happy to see uh estonian business in
ukraine
uh uh we are interested in their
increment um and uh invite ethonian
investors
uh to take a more active part in the
infrastructure energetical and the i.t
um uh sector uh in the development of
i.t sector in ukraine uh separately
we've
spoke about the um uh uh
inviting estonian investors to the
ukrainian of uh different foundations uh
regarding the i.t
and we also discussed uh cyber security
we also have plenty of uh uh prospective
uh directions
for our corporations ukraine and estonia
they uh have full desire to take our uh
cooperation to a totally new um level
this visit is a clear indication of that
uh i thank you again for your very
important visit in this very important
moment in the ukrainian
uh
for the ukrainian society and ukrainian
independence
the president of estonia's statement
we stand united with ukraine we will not
walk away
we will continue to so support you
in every possible way
i praise the ukrainian leaders who
despite constant provocation remain calm
and expressed willingness to solve this
conflict peacefully
russia must end the intolerable
provocations stop fueling the conflict
which has been ongoing for
eight years moscow should immediately
and unconditionally
withdraw its forces from ukraine's
territory and its immediate city
we strongly condemn all military and
high reductions
against ukraine
we regret that despite
diplomatic efforts
there are no signals of willingness to
de-escalate
quite the opposite
the right build-up of russian forces
continues
including in belarus
i align myself with everyone
who wish
we would have a way to secure peace
through the force of diplomacy and
dialogue
indeed
it is a deceasing moment decisive moment
in the european history
president putin will answer to the
future generations
for his highland violent actions
but also we european
and western leaders
have a responsibility to step up to our
values our commitment to europe unite
united and at peace
we regret every
single life lost
in this conflict
it is our duty
to protect our common values and the
democracy we all helped to build
a threat to ukraine is a threat to a
security of europe
the minimum we can do
is to step up our practical support to
ukraine
which estonia has done and will
continue to do so
in the eu
we will deliver on a massive package of
sanctions and do so swiftly and
decisively
but most importantly we must keep the
draw
for eu
and nato open for ukraine
and we must have concrete next steps for
further cooperation and integration
we know you will continue to value
democracy
and remain on behalf of reforms
eventually
we will welcome you as a member of a
european union
you belong in europe
we support
ukraine's independence sovereignty and
territorial integrity
we remain fully committed to a policy of
non-recognition of illegal and action of
ukraine's territories
ukraine
has a right to defend its borders and
independence and we continue helping
ukraine to build these military
capabilities to stand
against regression
thank you